take down
so if you've been playing Halo 5s new
warzone mode you probably encounter the
requisition system it's basically the
new version of player progression and it
affects warzone in a huge way you can
call it power weapons character upgrades
and game changing vehicles provided you
have enough points to spend but it can
be a little confusing at first both in
terms of acquiring new requisition cards
and spending them on the battlefield so
let's get to it to acquire new items
abilities and vehicles you'll have to
collect requisition cards and there are
two types of these certifications and
one-time use cards let's call these
burners certifications increase the
chance of getting that same item in
future packs
burner cards on the other hand are
limited but allow you to actually order
the item during a fight and that's where
requisition packs come in much like real
world trading cards these packs are
random the first way to earn new patch
is to spend req points you gather these
just by finishing matches completing
challenges or ranking up your overall
character level there are three tiers
each with their own prices bronze silver
and gold each of these grants a higher
chance at rare gear so it's probably
worth saving up for the better ones
you'll be unlocking new packs through
other avenues as well completing
challenges winning matches and
performing well in general are all
grounds for possible new packs each with
their own chances at rare loot so all
that's left now is how to spend the
packs there are two opportunities to use
cards in warzone during your respawn or
at rec consoles and each captures on
your team controls throughout each match
you'll increase what's called your req
level up to a maximum nine tiers if you
increase this simply kill enemy Spartans
eliminate AI minions or take over
capture zones themselves every action
that Awards you points will also
contribute to your req level and in
order to get better weapons and better
vehicles you'll need more req level
points it's rare that you'll achieve the
maximum level anytime before halfway
through the match but every once in a
while your points can pile up quickly so
if you get the chance to order a
legendary weapon or a scorpion tank when
you
really need to get a legendary boss so
that's the rec system although there is
a learning curve with Halo 5 new
progression economy it's an effective
way to bring you back to multiplayer
week after week developer 343 industries
plans on releasing free maps throughout
the year so keeping your inventory stock
could give you an edge in future warzone
matches if you have any further
questions about war zone or the
requisition system or any tips for other
players including myself feel free to
leave them in the comments below until
then stay tuned to game spot Nam
you